I love the Rocky movies they're not all
great great ones in there okay okay give
me your score out of 10 for each of your
Rocky movies uh Mr Number One 10 I think
so I think we'd go 10 out of 10 for
number what an incredible movie Rocky
number two uh I'd say about seven and a
half yeah I think you're being generous
number
three three I like three I have to go up
to I love three I have to go up to about
nine cuz three is the one where you got
Mr T in it AR it yeah absolutely that's
great film uh four toughest one of all
the hardest hitter Dolph ler I have to
give it like it well a lot of Montage I
give that about seven pretty good I like
that I like the training sequence he
uses Hightech training exactly Rocky
just drags a log behind him and chases a
chicken lucky five uh zero no was it
that bad lucky it was bad I don't
remember being quite as bad it's just it
was goose egg I was definitely not there
that's one of the reason I wanted to do
the last one because I said you know if
if you're going to end up on doing
something like you can't so bad so off
key that was the impetus to do the and
the last one actually wasn't called
Rocky s it was Rocky Bal which means the
end